mehr als 100 millionen menschen sind
derzeit auf der flucht wir geben einen
überblick über die situation weltweit
und schauen auf die größten krisenherde
in europa
asien
afrika und
amerika
[Musik]
aktuell sind deutlich über die hälfte
der flüchtenden binnenvertriebene von
den mehr als 33 5 millionen die ihr land
verlassen haben sucht der größte teil in
direkten nachbarstaaten schutz oft sind
krieg und gewalt die ursache aber auch
verfolgungen aus ethnischen religiösen
oder geschlechtsspezifischen gründen
zwingt viele zur flucht ebenso armut und
hunger die durch naturkatastrophen und
die folgen des klimawandels noch
verschlimmert werden
[Musik]
ukraine mehr als acht millionen menschen
befinden sich auf der flucht innerhalb
des landes darunter viele familien mit
kleinen kindern älteren oder chronisch
kranken person aus den stark umkämpften
gebieten besonders im osten versuchen
sie sich richtung westen in sicherheit
zu bringen
den flüchtenden fehlt es vor allem an
bargeld medizin und für jene artikel
weitere 65 millionen hauptsächlich
frauen und kinder suchen schutz im
ausland
viele wollen jedoch so bald wie möglich
wieder in ihre heimat schätzungsweise
sind über 15 millionen bereits
zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
syrien seit kriegsbeginn 2011 musste
über die hälfte der bevölkerung ihr
zuhause verlassen rund 6,9 millionen
menschen sind innerhalb des landes auf
der flucht
die anderen 6,85 millionen sind ins
ausland geflohen von ihnen ist fast die
hälfte minderjährig die meisten
flüchtlinge kamen in die türkei
mehr als eine million erreicht er die eu
myanmar anfang 2000 21 kam es zum
militärputsch seitdem ist die situation
vor allem für die muslimische minderheit
der rohingya noch gefährlicher sie
werden schon seit jahrzehnten brutal
verfolgt über eine million häuser sind
inzwischen aus dem mehrheitlich
buddhistischen land geflohen die meisten
nach bangladesch dort leben sie unter
menschenunwürdigen bedingungen in der
größten flüchtlingsunterkunft der welt
afghanistan seit der machtübernahme
durch die taliban im vergangenen jahr
hat sich die lage wieder stark
verschlechtert die bevölkerung leidet
unter terror dürren und hunger
rund 3,4 millionen binnenvertriebene
leben in afghanistan
weitere 2,7 millionen haben ihr
heimatland verlassen
die meisten von ihnen befinden sich in
pakistan und dem iran
deutschland steht an dritter stelle der
aufnahmeländer
[Musik]
südsudan auch wenn der 2013
ausgebrochenen bürgerkrieg offiziell
beendet ist kommt es immer wieder zu
massiver gewalt fast ein drittel der
bevölkerung ist durch den konflikt
entwurzelt viele sind in nachbarländer
geflohen vor allem nach uganda in den
sudan und äthiopien
auch in anderen afrikanischen staaten
sind menschen gezwungen ihre heimat zu
verlassen aufgrund von armut hunger und
naturkatastrophen
etwa jeder fünfte flüchtling weltweit
lebt südlich der sahara
[Musik]
venezuela
seit dem amtsantritt von präsident ma
doro ist die wirtschaft um zwei drittel
geschrumpft das geld hat durch
hyperinflation stark an wert verloren
selbst grundnahrungsmittel sind für
viele unbezahlbar
das gesundheitssystem ist
zusammengebrochen daher haben
mittlerweile viele venezolanerinnen ihr
land verlassen ihre hauptziele kolumbien
brasilien peru und chile
weltweit steigt die zahl der
vertriebenen seit zehn jahren und das
wird sie wohl auch weiter denn die
meisten fluchtursachen sind ungelöst und
es kommen weitere hinzu